من بين شخصيات اقتصاديه عديده في السويد
يتردد اسم سيده الناجحه تعتل منصات رياده
المال والاعمال امراه بالف رجل نجحت بحفظ
ارث عائلتها الذي تناقلته خمسه اجيال حتى
الان هذه السيده هي انطونيو جونسون التي
تتربع على ثروه تقدر بنحو تسعه مليارات
وخمسمائه مليون دولار فما سر هذه الثروه
ولدت انطونيا جونسون عام
1943 في نيويورك وتلقى التعليمها هناك ثم
حصلت على درجتها الجامعيه من كليه ردليف
المتخصصه في تدريس الفنون للاناث قبل ان
تنتقل الى السويد للحصول على الماجستير في
علم النفس والاقتصاد من جامعه ستوكهولم
بدات انطونيا حياتها المهنيه في مجموعه
جونسون الاقتصاديه حيث كان يديرها انذاك
والدها اكسل اكس جونس فيما اسسها جد
والدها اكسل جونسون في عام
1873 عندما كان في التاسعه والعشرين من
عمره كان اساس الشركه التي انطلقت من
استوكهولم تصدير الحديد واستداد الفحم قبل
ان تدخل في صناعه الشحن عمل اكسيل الجد
على تطوير مجالات عمل الشركه واشترى كامل
اسهمها قبل وفاته عام 1910 لتنقل الشركه
لخلفه اكسل اكس مع ثروه كبيره واملاك
عقاريه تولى اكسل اكس الشركه لاكثر من
خمسه عقود ونجح في توسيع اعمالها كما انشا
اول اسطول محيطيا كامل المحركات في العالم
واول مصفاه نفط بالدول الاسكندنافيه عند
وفاته في عام
1958 كان لديه 100 فرع يعمل فيها اكثر من
22 الف موظف بحجم مبيعات يقدر بمليار
وخمسمائه مليون سويديه كان والد انطونيا
مهندس التعدين اكسل اكس جونسن قد خلف
والده في اداره الشركه فقام بتقسيمها الى
قسمين
نمت مجموعه اكسل جونسون التي ضمت مجموعتين
ايضا احداهما في نيويورك والاخرى
بستوكهولم كما اسس شركه جي اس سابا
للفاكهه والخضروات ومجموعه الصناعيه
دلاله تلك الفتره كانت انطونيا بمثابه يد
يمنى لوالدها وكانت غالبا نائبه رئيس مجلس
الاداره قبل ان يتقاعد والدها في عام
1979 حيث بدات تتولى الامور بشكل مباشر
وتراست مجلس اداره التكتل توفي والد
انطونيا في عام
1988 ما جعلها وحيده في مهب الركود
الاقتصادي الذي القى بظلاله على العالم
الغربي في نهايه الثمانينيات وبدايه
التسعينيات حينها توقفت عمليات التجاره
والتوزيع لبعض المنتجات فركزت انطونيو على
التجاره الدوليه واسست مسارا محليا جديدا
هو تجاره التجزئه والبقاله طورت انطونيو
عمل التكتل وبات يضم علامات تجاريه اخرى
مثل داجاب وهم كوب والينس قبل ان تسلم
الاداره لابنتها كارولين بيرج في عام 2015
لتشرف عن بعد على المجموعه التي امتلكت
مصالح في الطاقه والعقارات والمنتجات
الصناعيه وسلاسل متاجر البقاله بفضل
نجاحها في قياده التكتل في اصعب الاوقات
حصلت انطونيو على لقب سيده العام المهنيه
عام
1987 وامراه العام الماليه في العام
التالي كما حصدت العديد من التكريمات
لاحقا لكن اهم ما خرجت به من الازمه كان
تسجيل منظمه انطونيو جونسون لدعم البحث
العلمي حول التنميه المستدامه ومواجهه اي
تحديات اقتصاديه كبرى كازمه الانكماش التي
مر بها العالم الغربي انذاك
[موسيقى]